every day people take pictures in
Hollywood sometimes it's tourists using
a mobile phone to take a picture of
their favorite star on the Walk of Fame
sometimes it's paparazzi snapping photos
of a celebrity leaving a restaurant
there are even surveillance cameras on
practically every street corner and then
there are people like Shawn nee an
award-winning street and documentary
photographer I live in Hollywood so I
tend to focus on you know my community
where they focus a lot on the
marginalized community within my
neighborhood over the years nee has
collected a trove of intimate moments
across a place that can seem glamorous
and muted simultaneously taking photos
is a part of who I am it's almost like
innate in me it's just a part of my
personality and it's like I will always
do it and I just need to keep on taking
photos I think mostly people I
photograph we're friends and the camera
is just part of our friendship now you
may know nee already he's posted a few
videos to YouTube documenting his
conflicts with law enforcement over his
right to take pictures in public places
he says he never seeks the incidents out
they happen at the most surprising times
and for the most surprising reasons
she's trying to stand up for what's
right you know the rights of
photographers and and everybody else who
wants to take a picture in public space
but one of those encounters that a
Hollywood subway stop in October 2009
was different from the rest and new
information about it reveals how easy it
is for one to go from photographer to
suspected terrorists well I had spent
all afternoon in Hollywood Highland area
taking photos it was Halloween weekend I
was coming home - so I was on my way
home from doing that the turnstiles in
the subway had come under public
scrutiny Sony decided to take a few
photos of them for a local news website
before he left the station took two
photographs of the turnstiles and then
was approached by a deputy killfeed you
know
take a picture there's no set you
against photos only mention why are you
taking pictures necklace deputy Richard
Gill fee is a terrorism liaison officer
and on this day he and his partner
deputy Roberto Bey's were patrolling the
subway stop at Hollywood Boulevard at
Western for potential homeland security
activity or suspicious activity that may
have a nexus to terrorism there are
individuals that are taking photographs
and are filming security sites for ill
deeds for terrorist activities Steven
Whitmore is the senior media advisor for
the Los Angeles County Sheriff's
Department and so we are very vigilant
about making sure that that's not
happening I want to know if you are
photography is not a crime it's artistic
expression Peter b-bring is a senior
staff attorney at the American Civil
Liberties Union of Southern California
and is representing me in a lawsuit
against the Sheriff's Department there's
no reason to believe that the just the
fact he's taking photographs he's
engaged in any kind of criminal or
terrorist activity millions of Americans
every day use their cell phone cameras
pointed shoots up to professional-grade
cameras to just document the lives
around them to snap a funny moment
between friends or a little piece of
beauty nestled in an urban environment
in public spaces on public streets no
law bars people from taking photographs
well you're gonna cooperate with me or
not I'm asking if I've seen the tape for
what purpose I just told you it's not
illegal to take photos I already asked
you one time
the officers took off knees messenger
back that the camera was clipped too and
put it on the ground
deputy guilty then held knees hands
behind his back and patted down me and
searched through his pockets the way
that this is done is clumsy at best and
probably a violation of someone's rights
Laurie Levenson is a professor of
criminal law and a former federal
prosecutor I think what's troubling is
everybody is wary of where is the
terrorism and for the local law
enforcement they don't want to be the
one who's caught missing something so
what has happened is that they've gone
from the traditional job of catching
crime to really pretending that they are
out to save the nation by seeing
terrorism all over the place and they
don't really have a firm understanding
of how far the Fourth Amendment allows
them to go and how long the First
Amendment protects the suspect their
training focuses them they know what to
look for and what not look at what not
to look for however having said that it
is an evolving process
we are getting better at this a training
manual used by the department from
August 2010 lists the number of
surveillance indicators the manual
encourages officers to be suspicious of
picture taking or video recording around
them especially with high magnification
lenses the manual goes on to list other
indicators like note-taking at non
tourist locations and taking pictures of
railroad tracks bus terminals and street
signs one is that that's a pretty broad
standard you know picture taking of a
sign a street sign somehow becomes
alleged terrorist activity so it's
probably over broad the second thing is
more how are they trained to be
suspicious and then react the suspicion
at one point things escalate and guilty
begins to threaten knee
on one level you're thinking is this
really happening and then one of another
level you just think this shouldn't be
happening it's one thing to go up to
somebody and say why are you taking
pictures or tell me about your
background it's another to say if you
don't cooperate if you don't stop I'm
gonna put you on a watch list your life
is going to be a living hell that's not
the job of law enforcement after deputy
guilty and deputy Bay's didn't find any
warrants out on me he was let go after
he filed a complaint saying that his
first and Fourth Amendment rights were
violated an internal investigation was
launched and at the conclusion of that
the appropriate action was taken I wish
I could tell you more but because of the
peace officers Bill of Rights I cannot
but I can say this specifically to you
the appropriate action was taken this is
the internal affairs Bureau
investigation report that contains the
information Whitmore can't talk about
the department defends the officers in
the report saying that they've been
trained in procedures used by terrorists
and are hypersensitive to indicators
such as the behavior and evasive nasaan
by knee you know it's a little troubling
in the ia report though actual words
that they use to try to defend the
officer one would expect that they would
describe the officer as professional and
even sensitive to what's happening on
the street but they used the word
hypersensitive which seems to suggest
that he might see terrorism where others
do not that he's over the top in the way
he reacts to what would be conduct on
the street the report comes to the
conclusion that the vigilance shown by
deputy guilty and detecting suspicious
activity is laudable and we are
encouraging others to be as proactive
what's even stranger is that even though
the deputies couldn't find any reason to
arrest me we now know that deputy Gil
fees submitted knees name to the FBI he
submitted it through a suspicious
activity report to the
Angeles joint Regional Intelligence
Center a fusion center which is in line
with department policy when identifying
suspicious activity fusion centers
collect and analyze data from multiple
law enforcement agencies while vocal and
federal trying to stop major crimes of
terrorism before they happen that raises
concerns that people who are engaged not
only in lawful activity but actually
constitutionally protected expression
are in this database where they're
identified as engaging in activity that
may have a link to terrorism and we're
not sure exactly what results that may
lead to what happens when that
individual is stopped for a traffic
violation what happens when that
individual tries to fly in the country
what I'm saying is is that if we have
got probable cause we are going to
investigate that to protect the public
and most of the time I submit to you
we're going to be right the Northern
California affiliate of the ACLU
recently released over a hundred
suspicious activity reports submitted to
the Joint Regional Intelligence Center
that have to do with cameras all of them
originated from the LA Sheriff's
Department the vast majority of them
seem completely innocuous they're simply
the fact that somebody was taking
pictures of a building at a subway
station some of them even of a skyline
the downtown LA skyline if looking for
terrorists is looking for a needle in a
haystack we seem to be adding not just
more hay to the haystack but more hate
more and more haystacks of information
every day it's not like law enforcement
doesn't have a legitimate reason to be
concerned could there be terrorists on
the streets are they trying to gain
intelligence or taking photographs for a
nefarious reason but it seems like it's
gone too far
you know the 9/11 mentality that there
are terrorists everywhere could untrue
to on everybody's constitutional rights
it means any time you take out a camera
and Hollywood or somewhere else you
could be a terrorist they can stop they
can hassle you they can put you on a
watch list I don't think anyone wants to
go in that direction and I don't even
think it's effective law enforcement you
can get and end up getting so much
information
that most of it is not useful and you're
missing the needle in the haystack
eventually everything is going to be
suspicious or criminalized and that's
not the world we want to live in that's
not you know the society that we're
supposed to you be part of standing up
for